for the second time this month
Venezuela's opposition majority leader
Huang Guido was obliged to improvise a
parliamentary chamber in a remote
auditorium hours earlier armed groups
loyal to the government had prevented
opposition lawmakers from approaching
the National Assembly firing weapons
using a crowbar to attack one of their
vehicles some deputies managed to pass
police barriers and were brutally
ambushed they have taken over the palace
militarily and fundamentally the groups
aren't by the dictatorship heavily armed
security forces had already surrounded
the legislative palace where Gua had
planned to convene Parliament meanwhile
government strongman Gustavo Correa
arrived chair the Constituent Assembly a
rival legislative super body created by
President Nicolas Maduro that operates
from the same building
he told Al Jazeera the opposition didn't
have anything more to do in Parliament
in fact it's not clear whether the
mainstream opposition will ever be able
to hold another session here in the
legislative palace again a government
strategy seems to be to occupy this area
permanently the next step will likely be
to allow the Supreme Court
controlled by Maduro loyalists to
appoint a new electoral council it's not
possible to reach an agreement in
Parliament as stipulated in the
Constitution the Supreme Court has the
right to declare a legislative omission
and proceed to make the appointment last
January the United States and more than
50 other countries recognized why though
the president of Parliament as the
country's interim president as well they
argued that Maduro had rigged his 2018
reelection but a year later harsh
economic and diplomatic sanctions to try
to force Maduro to hold new national
elections have failed and it's now while
off who's on the defensive as the
military-backed government uses all the
means at its disposal to isolate a
defiant but increasingly powerless
opposition
you see a Newman al-jazeera Caracas